I don't think you determine what your
purpose is I think you discover what
your purpose is there's a difference
this is all we've got right here right
now we don't know how much we have left
in the future but we do know what we've
got now 95% of the people live their
entire life and never lived the way they
want to live do you know that the law of
attraction is always working it's like
the law of gravity if I let this go it's
going to go down it's never going to go
back up it's going to go down he's
widely regarded as one of the Living
masters and teachers of the law of
attraction for over 50 years he's
transformed the lives of people through
his books seminars and personal coaching
he worked shoulder-to-shoulder with Earl
Nightingale in the 60s and 70s he's Bob
Proctor and here's my take on his top 10
rules for success rule number five is my
personal favorite and make sure to stick
around although to the end for some
special bonus clips and as always if bob
says something that really really
resonates with you please leave it down
the comments below and put quotes around
it so other people can be inspired as
well enjoy
I don't think you determine what your
purpose is I think you discover what
your purpose is there's a difference
determining indicates deciding and I
don't think you decide I think if you go
about it the right way you discover it
like there's some people that should be
painting all day
they're great artists make necklines law
was obviously a great artist
great sculptor I mean that was his
purpose in his life well I believe my
purpose is doing what I'm doing
your purpose is why you get out of bed
in the morning do you know why you get
up well most people say well it's their
go to work well that'd be a good reason
to stay in bed you know you say well
everybody's doing it that would be
another reason to stay in bed if you're
overdoing what everybody's doing you're
probably going in the wrong direction
your purpose is your reason for living
what you want to do is sit down and
maybe take a pen and a pad and then ask
yourself what do I really love doing now
you may have to spend a while at this
you might get up an hour early every
morning and go sit under a tree
somewhere if you're in a nice climate or
pick a favorite chair someplace where
you're not going to be disturbed and
totally relaxed and say if I could spend
my life doing something what do I really
love doing now since you don't ask
yourself that question every day it
might take a while for this answer to
come to the surface but it comes to your
consciousness and it may take a while
you may have to do this every morning
for three months but it would be well
invested the time how many times you had
somebody say to you have you got a
minute Bob you got a minute
then one
would you think about that I read a poem
one time said I have only just a minute
only 60 seconds in it it was forced upon
me I can't refuse it I didn't seek and I
didn't choose it but it's up to me to
use it I must suffer if I lose it
give a count if I abuse it it's only a
tiny little minute but eternity isn't it
well any rate I thought I'm going to put
this on a video I'm just going to share
with everybody just this one little part
out of the seminar I'm making I want you
to look at this Sam timer and let this I
want you to think about your life the
sand in the top of the glass represents
the future the sand in the bottom of the
glass represents the past now Genoa we
know what's in the past and young we
can't do anything about it you know what
the trick is you don't know how much
sand is in the top of the glass you may
think you have a lot you might only have
a little then again you may think you
have a little and you might have a lot
when I was a little boy I was raised by
my grandmother and I don't know when I
was little gaffer she would probably 60
but as long as I can remember redwood
saying I'll soon be gun deer I'll soon
be gun well you know we loved her she
was really an angel of God but we
thought she was never going to go she
lived to be 94 for 30-some years I'll
soon be gone she didn't think she had
much time left she had 34 years left now
about the same time I had a buddy of
mine Bob Yates he was just 16 and bang
he run into the abutment of a bridge and
his life was snuffed out if you had
asked him a half-hour before how much
sand he had left he would have said at
least a half a century he didn't have a
half an hour see the trick is we don't
know how much sand we have left the
future we don't know the past it's gone
now the only thing you can deal with is
what's right here right now and if you
look the sand is always moving now think
of this you see I was working on that
and then I was working on a graph I've
got here on my computer and I'm thinking
of the time somebody say - have you got
a minute
well they don't really want to men
you know if you're earning $50,000 a
year a minutes 42 cents a half-hour is
$12.50 if we take that ahead a bit if
you're earning $80,000 a year a minute
67 cents half hours $20 during a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars a year got a
minute and then it cost you a dollar 25
a minute a half hours thirty seven
dollars and fifty cents so if you see if
somebody said you want to stop for a cup
of coffee well if you're earning a
quarter of a million dollars a year a
minute is two dollars and eight cents
half hours sixty two dollars and fifty
cents and then of course you've got the
coffee to pay for on top of that so do
you see the point is this this is all
we've got right here right now we don't
know how much we have left in the future
but we do know what we've got now and I
have found the people that win are the
people who make up their mind they're
not going to waste the minutes they're
going to be productive they're going to
make it happen every minute the success
was the progressive realisation of a
worthy ideal anyone that has a goal and
they're moving towards it they're
successful
most people think that you're successful
if you have a lot of money quite often
you have a lot of money if you're
successful but it isn't I wouldn't say
mother Teresa has a lot of money okay
but she's a pretty successful lady so
it's said that barrier tizzies well
there's that there's a couple of them
okay I think there's two barriers one is
our conditioning the conditioning that
takes place in our subconscious mind
from the time were infants all we can do
is act and talk like the people around
this that's why we learn the language we
learned that there was ten languages
spoken in our home we learn ten
languages without any trouble there's
usually one and that's the only one we
ever learned we grow older we think I
couldn't learn another language we had
learned a hundred if we wanted to you
can do anything but I think we're
conditioned we have a real strong
conditioning usually with not some very
good ideas and then that that's the the
barrier that's inside is the one that's
outside of us as our environment we have
a tendency to act like everybody around
and if you think about this it doesn't
make a lot of sense because if you study
statistics 95% of the people live their
entire life and never live the way they
want to live you know that 95% of the
population in this country let's say in
North America okay
the richest continent in the history of
the world they all work productively
let's say for 40 of their 65 years okay
and they'll end up with hardly any money
there's gotta be something wrong so just
note why 5% of the people end up
financially comfortable or independent
are you trying to depress this bump
because that's no actually I think it's
I think it's quite an exciting idea
because you see the idea behind it is
that anybody can win anyone at all but
if we start studying these statistics I
think we'll arrive at the conclusion
geez I better start thinking for myself
rather than follow everybody most people
they get a job they look around to see
how everybody else is doing their work
and they start doing it the same way
they should stop and think I wonder if
any of these people know what they're
doing is there a better way to do it but
don't we have a need to fit in I mean we
don't want it we don't want to stand out
we don't to get fired
we don't make waves exactly exactly just
fall into line you know take a number be
like everybody around now that'd be
great in the animal kingdom and but
human beings aren't supposed to live
that way I think we should make a few
waves we should maybe stand out be
different not not for the sake of being
different okay but because we are
different we all think different
thoughts and I believe we should start
to think and build images in her mind of
what we'd like to do and then set up and
do it okay that Merson did that Edison
did that Marconi did that Samuel Morse
did that [ __ ] Minister fuller did that
we could go on and on and on
okay we're different they stood out they
made a few waves you should seek
failures see if you're playing it safe
you're not going to win if you're
playing it safe like that all say you
know you're topping your little girl
better to be safe than sorry well that's
a bunch of crap it's not better be safe
than sorry
it's by trying things that you figure
out how far you can go you got to get
outside the box
like it's reported Edison tried 3000
ways before he built incandescent light
he said he didn't deal 3000 times he
said there was 3,000 different steps to
building a light bulb well there's
different steps to get to where you're
going and I really do treat winning and
losing exactly the same I do not let it
upset me do you think that's a big part
of why you're so successful well it's
part of why I enjoy it yeah I think it
is because I'll try anything like if if
I'm into an idea the idea of losing
never enters my mind see I have worked
with giants I had the good fortune of
working with Sir Edmund Hillary he was
the first man to stand on top of the
world and I worked with him on three
different occasions and the only
difference in ed Hillary and Bob Proctor
is in his his size now he's gone now but
he was a big man when he struck hands
with me his hand wrap right around mine
I felt like Oh
dwarf you know and and talked into him
like it never entered his mind he
wouldn't get to the top of the mountain
but he failed in 1951 he failed in 1952
it wasn't until 1953 that he got to the
top of the mountain no people had died
for centuries trying to do that he said
I knew if I could see it in here I could
hold it out here still a man wrote that
in the book you can see it in your head
you can hold it in your hand
and that's right and if you're not
prepared to lose you're never gonna win
because you're always playing it safe
and there's no there's no reward in that
look at these two men do you know who
they are
most people don't they're just a couple
of ordinary guys one they're both gone
now but one was an ordinary beekeeper in
Auckland New Zealand and the other a
Sherpa guide from over around Nepal now
there's Mount Everest
you know for thousands of years people
had tried to get to the top of Mount
Everest people died doing it it was
believed it couldn't be done people
tried but they didn't know how
and so they quit there's a closer look
at the mountain and where they place
their flag they planted that flag in the
mountain now this is the two of them
after they come down the mountain and
you know something when they started
they did not know how they didn't know
how to get to the top of the mountain
and that's what stops most people
because they don't know how as little
kids we'd go mummy daddy I want this
they say how are you going to do that
well as a little kid you don't know how
to do it but they did it in 1953 on the
29th of May they were the first to to
get to the top of that mountain they
stood right on top of the world do you
know there's been over a thousand people
do it since then I watched a young woman
on Canadian television being interviewed
not very big she had just come back from
going to the top of Mount Everest and
the reporter asked her they said how
does it feel now that you conquered the
mountain she didn't conquer the mountain
that mountain can't be conquered we
conquered the limitations that are
within ourselves select the person who
is already doing something that you'd
like to do get to know that person go to
the experts for advice don't ask the
person next door your mother father
brother the guy works beside you because
they don't necessarily know there's no
point in asking a person how to earn a
lot of money if they're only earning ten
thousand a year they don't know they
knew they'd probably be earning a lot
it's like I don't go to a sick doctor if
you want to get healthy okay so you find
someone that you can go to for advice
get a real good book and lock into that
book and start to study it like I bet
this one looks like a Bible you know but
this is Napoleon Hills book Think and
Grow Rich I've been reading this thing
now for 23 years I'll probably read it
for another 23 years I get another good
book they're brought over here today
it's called the power of your
subconscious mind I'm not getting the
Commission for selling this the author's
dead now he's been gone for a couple of
years but dr. Joseph Murphy wrote this
book the power your subconscious mind
and that's probably one of the best
books that you're ever going to find
because you're going to learn something
about your mind when you read this book
okay now I read a lot of books I've got
probably a thousand books sitting in my
den at home in my library but the one
that I carry I carry it everywhere I go
and I read it all the time is Think and
Grow Rich and ever stop reading it
where's the value for you to reread that
rebound
I mean you must you must know it well
that I think I could probably recite it
verbatim but the secret is I once read
in the book where it said when you read
a good book through the second time you
don't see something in it that you
didn't see before you see something in
yourself that wasn't there before
you see when I read this I created a
greater awareness you know many years
ago I read a book by Terry Cole Whitaker
it was a classic what you think of me is
none of my business
think of the amount of time that is
wasted on negative energy wondering what
other people think of you what they
think of you really doesn't make any
difference
it's what you think of you that makes a
difference so as you go through the day
don't worry about what other people
think of you just say I'm all right I'm
God's highest form of creation see this
line that's called the terror barrier
yeah jumping out isn't it and on the
other side of the terror barrier is
something we call freedom and you know
very few people get through that terror
barrier that's rather sad freedom is
available to everyone there isn't anyone
that could not live the way they want to
live saying why don't they why don't
they they don't know and they don't even
know they don't know now I'm going to
show you why people experience buyer's
remorse when they buy something really
want and then they back away where they
go to move and they don't they go to
change jobs they don't they go to move
to another city and they don't why fear
causes them to stay where they are
there's the individual the X represents
the unknown factor the paradigm now
there's a power flowing into this
individual's mind and they can make
anything out of it they want remember we
said we have the ability to choose what
do they choose they choose thoughts that
are in harmony with the paradigm now
here's an important point the paradigm
controls the vibration
this thing we call our body our body is
a molecular instrument that's really
what it is it's a mass of molecules and
a very high speed of vibration the
vibration that the body's in on a
conscious level we call feeling when a
person says they feel this way or they
feel that way what they're really doing
is describing the vibration they're in
now they choose thoughts that harmonize
with the vibration they're in so they
feel comfortable they may not like the
results but they're comfortable now
let's move ahead let's take a look here
those people are getting X tape results
and they don't like it do you know what
the problem with them they're in bondage
these people are locked up you know
paradigm is like keeping a person in a
prison only there's no locks on the door
they can open the prisoner walk out into
freedom anytime they want and they don't
they keep getting the same results over
and over and over again they're in
bondage now let's go ahead here's the
same person X type conditioning X type
vibration the power is flowing into them
and for some strange reason from left
field bone in comes a Y type idea what
is the Y type idea the Y type idea
represents anything that you might want
to do that you're not doing it might be
moved to another city changed jobs sell
the house buy the farm whatever it may
be ask the little girl for the date ask
the guy to go to lunch go make the sale
buy what you want go where you want to
go that's the Y idea but as long as the
Y idea is just in the conscious mind
it's just going to be an intellectual
exercise it's never going to happen so
how do we make it happen
well that's when everything goes haywire
here we are here same person okay
the power flows in now what do they do
they got the Y type idea now for some
strange reason they know that they've
got to get emotionally involved if
they're going to act on that idea they
don't understand what's going
happen but clearly understand this your
central nervous system is the most
complex electrical system in the
universe the central nervous system is
mind boggling it would make the
electrical system in a supercomputer
look like a toy
now the second you take the idea from
your intellect and impress it upon the
subject of mind that's when all hell
breaks loose
because the body moves in to an X dot X
Y vibration it's not in the X vibration
not the one that we're comfortable with
me now like the results but we're
comfortable no on a conscious level
everything's going crazy on a conscious
level we experience dote the dope turns
into an emotion called fear and that
fear is expressed through the body as
anxiety see that person is getting
emotionally involved to move ahead do
you know what happens they hit that
terror barrier and they bounce off it
and right back into bondage and they're
so relieved to get back there they're
back where they're comfortable they've
cancelled the sale they've decided not
to move they're going to stay in the job
that they don't like at least they're
comfortable now that's not a very good
way to live and you know something
that's something everybody experiences
if they're going to grow you're going to
hit that terror barrier see the terror
barrier is going beyond where you're at
going to a new level
I'm going to tell you something when I
set a goal if if if it doesn't scare and
excite me at the same time I know I'm
going in the wrong direction now I also
understand that my paradigm is going to
try and get me to bounce back to where I
was it doesn't want me to move ahead I
don't want to live there I lived there
for the first 26 years of my life and
for the last 50 I've had a phenomenal
life and it just keeps getting better
and I want you to do the same thing
understand what I've just said I'm going
to back this up they got emotionally
involved in the Y idea that moved their
body into a different vibration on a
conscious level
they're experiencing some crazy stuff
they start to doubt their ability we'll
never be able to pay for it they
experience fear the fear expresses
itself as anxiety and bang you bounce
off that terror barrier and you're right
back oh I might not be earning much here
but I know what it is I I would love to
move there but I'm comfortable here I
think I'll just stay here these people
are acting like they have a contract I
live forever and they don't you know
what to do say I'm going to get rid of
all that I understand it's there but I
don't want any part of it and I'm going
to go crashing right through that terror
barrier now does that get rid of the X
energy no that's energy is still there
you see I don't least your over into
freedom you made the move you did it and
if you continue to feed the right
information into your mind keep feeding
that Y idea keep getting emotionally
involved in Hawaii idea you're there
you're on the road keep doing that
you're going to find that the paradigm
is going to change and it'll just all go
away and you know you're living in
freedom you're living where you want to
live buyer's remorse is when you cancel
the sale buyer's remorse is when you
stop just before you buy what you really
want before you go for the thing that's
going to change your life and you know
it it's not moving to the other city
it's not starting the business of your
dreams it's not stepping out and betting
on yourself
that's a terror barrier that's causing
that and if you don't learn to go
through the terror barrier I'm going to
tell you something you're going to stay
right where you are for the rest of your
days that's not a good place to be what
did Joseph Campbell say so true they
cave you fear to enter holds the
treasure you seek many years ago
I read where Napoleon Hill pointed out
that the imagination is the most
marvelous miraculous in a conceivably
powerful force that the world has ever
known
and you know the average individual uses
the imagination if they use it at all
against themselves they imagine what
they don't want they imagine problems
coming
let's begin to use our imagination the
way God intended to be used it's the
greatest creative faculty that we
possess and we can do anything we want
want you to wander around your home or
possibly your office and take a look at
all of the conveniences that you have
there
that you didn't have a Satan two years
five years ten years ago 25 years ago
do you know that every one of them
without exception was first created in
the mind of one individual with their
imagination do you know you can use your
imagination to win to the future and
bring it into the present that's what
all highly successful people do
they see where they want to go and then
they act like the person they want to
become it was William James from
Harvard's advice he says it's the actors
technique act like the person you want
to become how do you do that
will you use your imagination of course
to see it's a strange phenomena but the
greatest gift we've got is used very
well up to the ages of four or possibly
five the little child
we always wonder what's going on in
their mind they're using their
imagination their building wonderful
pictures in their mind but then they get
to school and WHAM like that it comes to
an abrupt halt it's called not paying
attention
daydreaming
well
what they were really doing was
exercising a phenomenal mental faculty
you see we can see hear smell taste
touch therefore our physical benefit as
long as we're living in a physical body
and corresponding with the material
world we will use our sensory factors
but you know I have a couple of little
dogs at home they can hear see smell
taste and touch we've got higher
faculties your perception the will
memory intuition reason and imagination
these marvelous tools
we can take our imagination and build an
image in our mind of how we want to live
block out what's going now don't let
your present results have anything to do
with this just what you want
and it's with your imagination duralumon
everything that we have the camera that
I'm speaking to right now was first
created in the mind of one individual
think of how our worlds changed
you see we were gifted with these higher
faculties we're God's highest form of
creation we were created in God's image
we were given creative faculties to use
and you know they're only used by two or
three percent of the population
it's almost inconceivable that we people
would wander around with so much power
and potential and squadron
see the average person literally tiptoes
through life hoping they make it saved
me to death
it's such a shame and it doesn't have to
be that way
think wheel giant corporations and
little weed creative departments the
primary reason for that is the average
individual really does not believe that
their great
everyone's creative and no one is more
creative than another it's just that
some have chosen to use their creative
faculties to a greater degree than
others
imagination your imagination what do you
want how do you really want to live
build the picture in your mind there's a
power that is flowing to and through you
a creative unadulterated power it can be
photographed leaving your body
way back in the 30 Semyon Kirlian the
russian photographer perfected apartment
photography where you can actually
photograph a person's body and you will
see the energy glowing from them
well that energy flows into your mind
and it's the images you build in your
mind that's going to dictate the
vibration that this instrument you're
living in is in and the vibration on a
conscious level is called feeling make
certain that you exercise your
imagination daily build beautiful images
in your mind of how you want to live and
then hold those pictures there and live
that way the imagination the greatest
nation in the world the imagination
you've got one
it's a marvelous creative tool
it deals with the invisible side of your
personality you see no one will ever
really see you they'll only see your
body and they'll see you the great work
that you do make certain that your work
is great work and if you keep your
imagination alive you're going to have a
phenomenal life you know life can get
better every day and it will get better
every day
through the proper use
of your imagination
what a wonderful
you know that the law of attraction is
always working it's like the law of
gravity if I let this go it's going to
go down it's never going to go back up
it's going to go down that is law of
gravity anything heavy earth is
attracted towards the center of the
world well the law of attractions always
working now how does it work well I use
a diagram to explain the mind now let
this circle represent your mind and let
this little circle here represent your
body now I want you to think of this for
a moment your body is a molecular
structure this is a mass of energy in a
very high speed of vibration if you
looked at your body through a microscope
you'd see that energy dancing right
before your eyes here's something
that'll keep you thinking for the next
twenty years when you move out of it the
body does not stop moving if you go to a
funeral parlor and pick up the remains
and look at it you will see it moving
and if it wasn't moving how would it
ever change the dust you move into your
body and you will move up and it's how
you use your mind that's going to
dictate the vibration you're in now stay
with me you have an imaginary line right
across here and that separates the
conscious mind from the subconscious
mind now the subconscious mind has been
programmed when you were a little baby
this is the way it was or just like this
subconscious mind wide open and
everything that was going on around it
went right in there and all the energy
that went in there when you were just a
little baby form something called a
paradigm now a paradigm is information
it's a multitude of habits you are the
product of your environment but prior to
that you are the product of a genetic
strain that goes back for generations
now I'm going to say that the paradigm
is X type energy
now you've got the ability here on a
conscious level to think and you can
think anything you want to think and as
you think you build ideas there's a
power that's flowing into your
consciousness it never stops it flows to
and through you you can actually
photograph this power leaving you it
flows to and through you now as it flows
in you will start thinking and you'll
probably think X type thoughts
therefore you're going to be in an X
type vibration and that will produce X
type results now it's the results you
want to change and to change the results
you're gonna have to change what you
attract to see the thoughts that you
think control the vibration that you're
in vibration is nothing but an idea it's
a law of the universe everything
vibrates nothing rests
we live in an ocean of motion and it's
the thoughts that you're thinking that
you impress upon your subconscious mind
that control the vibration the body's in
and that dictates how you act but it
also dictates what you attract you
attract energy that's in harmony with
you you attract people that are in
harmony with you you see everything
operates on frequencies there's an
infinite number of frequencies but you
and I operate on a frequency just like a
radio station does and the only music
you can attract is the music that is
tuned into the vibration you're in now
it's the paradigm that has been
controlling the vibration you can change
your thinking but that doesn't do
anything you really change the paradigm
and if you don't change the paradigm
nothing happens now talking about
paradigms is another subject we will do
that at another time but it's the
thoughts that you think they control the
vibration you're in and that dictates
what you attract so if you keep
attracting what you don't want
understand this it's the paradigm that's
causing the problem you can think a Y
type thought which is totally different
than the X type conditioning it is
going to go anywhere because when you go
to get emotionally involved and this is
the emotional mind when you go to get
emotionally involved with that white
tape done the paradigm will kick it up
you know why it's so uncomfortable
that's stepping out of the box that's
doing things different and we don't like
to do things different because it causes
a lot of discomfort but understand this
the paradigm and the thinking control
the vibration you're in then the
vibration is going to dictate what you
attract people that are in a poverty
consciousness will continue to attract
lack and limitation it has nothing to do
with this what's going on here this is
your educated mind and you can gather
all kinds of information have you ever
wondered why some people have such an
educated mind they have degrees coming
right off the end of their business card
but it doesn't show up in the results
why they're done the law of attraction
you've got to change this you've got to
change the vibration you're in and your
whole world changes listen in 1961 a man
gave me this book and he said do exactly
what I tell you he was giving me Y type
ideas it caused an enormous amount of
discomfort but I did exactly what he
said and you know something my income
went from a four thousand one hundred
and seventy five thousand in a year and
then I took it over a million it took me
nine and a half years to figure out what
this is what I'm showing you watch this
over and over and over again there's a
number of lessons in here and another
lesson I'm going to show you how to
change the paradigm when you change the
paradigm the change in results is
automatic you know what you start to
attract something they're something
different and what we want to do is
program in positive information and
eliminate the negative I'm going to show
you how to do a law of attraction you
are tracked according to the vibration
you're in this thing we live in is a
molecular structure your body is a
massive energy you know if you put your
body in front of an infrared television
camera and a completely dark room your
whole being would be nothing but a
glistening radiating gleaming form
feeling is conscious awareness of the
vibration we're in when we don't feel
good we're in a negative vibration I
want to feel good move into a positive
vibration stop and think of what you're
grateful for but understand this you
will never attract to you wealth
happiness health until you get the
paradigm get you on that frequency by
procter and thank you
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Pagla by asked
me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down the comments below
and I'll see what I can do
I don't celeb to know what did Bob say
that resonated with you the most what
rule had the biggest impact on you what
did you learn from this today that
you're going to apply to your business
or your life please share it leave in
the comments below I'm going to join in
the discussion thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself in
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
your vision is how you're going to
execute your purpose your purpose is why
you're living your vision is how you're
going to execute it so your vision would
be a long-range vision of a whole bunch
of things that you would love to do the
guy of all kinds of things I want to do
I'm when I'm in the air I spend almost
all my time hardly ever watch a movie or
anything like that I spend almost small
many time thinking and I think how can I
do what I'm doing better how can I do it
in a bigger way like we started
streaming club we have a streaming club
where I stream every week and we're
going to expand on that and that was the
result of me going into I went into Tel
Aviv to Cyprus to Melbourne to Auckland
to Los Angeles back to Toronto and the
people are all saying oh I just spent a
little time with you
that kind of should be able to spend
time with them but I had to catch
another plane and so the idea of the
streaming Club came to me so that was an
idea it was part of my vision and I
acted on it immediately so your vision
is a long-range view of all the things
that you'd like to do that are all on
purpose
every one of them would be helping you
execute your purpose cybernetics and
paradigms very very interesting subject
cybernetics and paradigms are both
control systems that operate essentially
on the same principle both maintain a
definite course of action and will not
deviate from the course that has been
established you must alter the paradigm
to achieve the result that you desire
now think about that for a moment you'll
see people stuck at a certain level go
ask any sales manager to give you the
names of their sales people and they can
tell you what those sales people are
going to do next month and next year why
because they're programmed they just
come in about the same maybe up and down
a little but they commit about the same
how about athletes every coach will tell
you exactly how they're going to play
theirs
patterns they're called habitual
patterns well that's a paradigm now this
is a beautiful concept so let's
understand it cybernetics and paradigms
alright there's a thermostat now a
thermostat in your home is a cybernetic
instrument now I live in Toronto so a
good part of the year it gets pretty
cold there and other parts of the earth
gets pretty warm but in the winter you
would have your thermostats set to
control the room temperature and around
70 degrees now you could be sitting
there reading a book or something and
all of a sudden you feel a draft around
your feet and you starting to feel a
little cool and you think what's going
on so you go and look at the thermometer
and you notice that the temperature is
not 70 it's dropped to 65 degrees you
start to investigate you think what's
wrong and you'll notice the front door
is open now it used to be when I was a
little boy you'd go and check on the
furnace because maybe the furnace had
gone out and you'd have to shake all the
ashes down and build another fire and
get it going again not today today we've
got cybernetic mechanisms hooked up to
our heating system you see the
thermostat measures the deviation from
the set goal what was the set goal to
set goals 70 but the temperature is at
65 things have changed the thermostat
sends a message to the furnace and
automatically the fires turned on the
fans turned on and the temperature
starts to rise and it gets up to 66 67
68 69 and it'll take a right back until
it's back on course at 70 degrees and
then the fire and the fan are turned off
now think of that and it all happens
automatically
that's a cybernetic mechanism
interesting isn't it
do you know you've got a cybernetic
mechanism in you let's look at it
another way let's look up the sky
there's a big plane now the automatic
pilot on a commercial plane is a
cybernetic instrument that's exactly
what it is and you see a
flight pattern is programmed into the
plane's computer system when the plane
goes off course the cybernetic system
measures the deviation from the set goal
and it corrects the flight pattern the
plane is brought back on course it's
correct correct correct correct correct
you know a rocket going to the moon is
off-course 97 percent of the time let's
take a look at it from a different
perspective there's a plane leaving
Chicago and it's flying to Paris now
when the plane leaves the vicinity is
just getting off the ground the wheels
are still down it's just getting up
there the automatic pilot is flipped on
the pilot could come back and have
dinner with you now they don't leave the
cockpit but they're not necessarily
doing it it's all done automatically and
you see when that planes flying along
you get hits by some turbulence gets
knocked off course you know what happens
the cybernetic mechanism cuts in it's
activated and it puts the plane back on
course again it's all happens
automatically pilot doesn't even have to
do anything but ultimately although goes
off course and gets knocked back on
course it ends up in Paris now think
about that for a moment here's you and
you have locked into your subconscious
mind a self image and that self image
operates like a cybernetic mechanism
okay your self image is a cybernetic
instrument now let's suppose your self
images that you are overweight know you
don't talk about it you don't want
anybody else to talk about it but inside
you feel you're overweight and you just
get to a point you can't handle anymore
so you make a decision I'm going to go
on a diet and you instantly move into
action now what happens well you start
to lose weight why you're starving
yourself you don't eat anything white
you know and on and on where you go no
more chocolate why because they make you
fat that's not what makes you fat it's
the image that makes you fat if you had
a skinny image you could eat all the
chocolate in the world you just pass off
what's not needed for the manifestation
on the image
through your eliminative system
eliminative system is one of the systems
in your body now here's the point when a
person who is overweight goes on a diet
without changing or altering the
self-image any weight loss is temporary
that's why people gain and lose tons in
a lifetime say they lose it you're
automatically programmed to find
whatever you lose the self-image being a
cybernetic instrument measures the
deviation from the set goal and
immediately corrects the course the
weight that was lost will be found you
see you look at the scales don't relate
that's not really me that's not really
me so what happens to let's put it back
on again
isn't that interesting I know if you
have a weight problem they're saying I
never knew that well now you do know it
but you see if you're going to change
the weight you've got to change the
paradigm that's what our company is all
about we help people change paradigms we
help them live in the body they want to
live in I'm so happy
grateful now that I'm at my perfect
weight I'm looking good down it went
great
you can do that you can live the way you
want to live your hug God's highest form
of creation where's another area that we
could use well you can use it in any
area let's take a child in school now
this is all in psycho cybernetics dr.
Maxwell Maltz his block and and here's
something else what's the point of
making heroic laws of amendment if the
same old lawbreakers can keep them I am
going to take the weight off but you
don't change the law breaker the
paradigm Emerson was right of what used
to make a row a pulse of amendment if
the same old law breaker is going to
keep them greatness comes from fantasy I
would imagine that when Edison first saw
the light bulb he was fantasizing but he
kept fantasizing and he built it into a
theory and then he built it into an
image and then he built it into a fact I
mean when I was a kid it was a fantasy
that they could going to the moon we've
been up there with cars playing golf